suecia no será el único país nórdico por
fuera de la otan siguiendo los pasos de
su vecino finlandia estocolmo anunció
sus intenciones de presentar formalmente
una solicitud de adhesión al bloque
militar el país pone así fin a dos
siglos de una histórica política de
neutralidad
stonesoft tras el debate en el
parlamento hemos celebrado una reunión
extra del gobierno y hemos decidido
informar a la otan que suecia desea
convertirse en miembro de la alianza con
fiat la alianza finlandia quien anunció
este domingo sus intenciones sostendrá
sesiones maratónicas en el parlamento
para llegar a un acuerdo aunque al menos
el 85% de los diputados apoya la
decisión de unirse el país comparte una
frontera de 1300 kilómetros con rusia y
siente la amenaza de su vecino ya que
fue invadida por la unión soviética en
1939 para putin quien asistía a la
conmemoración por los 30 años de la
organización del tratado de seguridad
colectiva que surgió como contrapeso de
las repúblicas ex-soviéticas a la otan
la llegada de estos dos países no
representa una amenaza real a menos de
que haya una expansión armamentista de
la alianza trasatlántica en estos
territorios
en cuanto a la expansión de la otan e
incluso a través de la inclusión de los
nuevos miembros de la alianza y en la
cndh yo y suecia quiero informarles que
ni los colegas que rusia no tiene ningún
problema con esos estados entonces en
este sentido la expansión por la adición
de nuestros países no representa una
amenaza directa para nosotros pero la
expansión de la infraestructura militar
en este territorio ciertamente
provocaría nuestra respuesta cuál sería
veremos que amenazas se crean para
nosotros dijo gross controlando ductos
de bots los ministros de exteriores de
los dos aspirantes nórdicos anunciaron
que viajarán pronto a turquía el único
país de la alianza que ha expresado
reticencias a la adhesión
ankara los acusa de acoger miembros de
organizaciones que considera terroristas
aunque ha reiterado su respeto por la
política de puertas abiertas de la otan